good morning my name is lucia gutierrez
and i'm an associate professor at the
university of wisconsin-madison and
today i'm going to talk about genomic
selection in syria but first i'd like to
thank elisabeth mark and all the
organizers at cornell for the invitation
so and we're going to start with some
breeding history you can see asteroid
history we have had tremendous uh grain
yield increases in mace production and
this is a consequence of the
main breeding targets of breeding and
also management
in terms of breeding targets the main
breeding target was yield
and the ultimate goal was food but today
we're facing new challenges so we have a
growing population that we're going to
need to feed we have a higher climate
variability and other
environmental impacts of agriculture
that we need to address and manage
consumers are demanding higher quality
and healthier food
and also we need to make sure that we
produce all this food
maintaining the livelihood of the
farmers and having communities that are
thriving
so all of this poses more challenges to
breeding efforts and we need to
be more efficient uh have
more precision
and make the breeding faster
so
for making this happen i'm going to
start with a breeding equation which is
this and the breeding equation or how
much response do we get from selection
it's a function of the intensity of
selection so uh how many individuals we
select out of the total population the
accuracy with which we evaluate those
individuals uh the genetic variance or
the square root of that and then the
time that it takes to uh go from one
cycle complete one full cycle
uh
and um my talk today is going to be
focus on line development so this is for
uh inbred species or
um hybrid species that use line
development to produce hybrids and um
i'm gonna separate two concepts and
we're going to walk through the
talk in two different components so one
is the population improvement
which is
the selection of the appearance the
intermediate and then the advancement of
those individuals until we make it into
the next appearance
and um so this is um just
one of the main goals of breeding is to
improve that population from which we're
going to be deriving individuals
and then for the release we need to
derive those uh lines and those could be
ingredients uh or we we are developing
those in red lines to produce a hybrid
so uh those cultivar development is the
second phase here on the right
where we use multiple year
evaluation multiple environments we do
selection for individuals now not for
breeding values
and then we release individuals of
course we are cycling all of this is not
disconnected they are all completely
connected and we're cycling individuals
back as parents so we're using different
strategies for selecting those parents
and um
one aspect that we can change is in this
breeding equation is time right how much
does it take to complete a full
generation uh until we can recycle the
parents back and for that there have
been several strategies that have work
some as double haploids that have worked
in many species and today i'm going to
talk a little bit about speed breeding
which is another strategy that helps in
decreasing the time that it requires to
complete a full cycle so in this case it
means the spree breeding and nothing
else and just manipulating uh the light
uh the photo period and the temperature
uh to together with the nutrients so
that we can make the plants flower
faster so that we can make them um
shorter times
and uh in this example uh what we did is
we evaluated those feed breeding in oats
uh and we found that we could go from
111 days to harvest
until 79. so that means that we can
increase and put a few more generations
in a year
when we are
doing this in our context we are using
it as a single seed descent strategy so
that we can
get fixed lines faster but there are
other ways in which we can use this
speed breathing
so this is one way that we can increase
uh the response to selection is by
decreasing the time
um how fast can we recycle the
appearance uh well we're still
evaluating a few options uh you can go
as fast as the s2 which would be very
similar to animal and breeding so these
concepts come from animal breeding
before uh hiki has been working a lot on
this population improvement and speed
and cultural development
um we can go as fast as we want uh it
depends on a few things uh our training
population how are we gonna be updating
those
and then our ability to um to screen
those individuals how many genotypes can
we score
in those
and then a few other concepts uh we
talked about
the variance how much
the genetic variance will affect uh the
response to selection so one way that
readers have always worked is we never
do crosses that are just the good by the
good
we also look for
different traits and complementarity of
traits and so we can use the same
strategies when we're looking at genomic
selection we can look at the cross
instead of the parents instead of
selecting the best parents we select the
best crosses that could potentially
produce a higher variance that could
produce a higher top 10 percent of the
individuals so these are some strategies
that we can use to increase the
response to selection
and this follows the work uh
by the group in minnesota with kevin
smith and others that have done this uh
software to to do this
uh
cross-election
other ways that we can improve i'm sorry
the response to selection is by
increasing the accuracy and we can play
with the accuracy in many ways and uh
you're probably seen and there's going
to be other talks that talk about uh
models and a few other things to do to
improve the accuracy uh here i'm gonna
focus on optimizing the training
population uh so this is
uh our main hypothesis was um if we have
a large number of individuals that were
genotyped and phenotyped uh and they are
you know part of our breeding program so
they are mildly related
um to the
testing individual to individuals we
would like to predict and our question
was uh so are we better off by using all
the individuals in the training
population or are we better off by
selecting a subset that is going to be
more productive of those individuals
that we would like to uh
predict on the testing and so here what
i have is uh this is the predictive
ability so the correlation between the
um
the observe and the predicted uh reading
values and this is the number of
individuals in the x-axis and you can
see here is the full population so if we
use all the individuals in this
population this is a predictability
we're going to get
for predicting new individuals
and so what we did is uh we evaluated a
few strategies some of them are like um
predicted our variance city means and a
few others that have been published and
then we propose this new strategy that
is based on
weighting a stratified sample of the
individuals based on the relationship to
the testing so that we make sure that we
always have a
highly related individual
of the testing in the training and then
also if we have some
structure in that population
that we are uh weighting them by those
groups so in that way uh what we call
this uh wc or weighted um
uh kinship matrix what we found is that
we had a higher predictive ability
we could find an optimal here
training population for those
individuals that was higher than the
random sample
and then the variance of a lot of
different random samples it was also
better than the cd mean and the pv
so these are strategies that we can use
to improve the predictive ability if we
know what individuals would like to test
um
other things that we need to take into
account when we're um
reading and we're trying to use as a
genomic selection
is uh how to optimize the training
population for the environment so the
target population of environment is very
relevant and just putting everything
together in the same bug might not be
the best strategy so we have shown that
uh using mg environments and protecting
within my environments or for predicting
new environment it's a good strategy or
just modeling the g by e if we have the
full uh matrix then those pre uh produce
higher productive ability so um those
are common practices in breeding but we
don't need we need to
remember to use those chives when we do
our
predictions
we can also use
it's highly recommended to use all the
available information so if we have
environmental coverage we can enrich our
productions we can increase our
productive ability by using all these
environmental covariates here are some
examples where predictive ability here
was increased by using those
environmental cover areas
um other ways that we can uh improve the
response to selection is by managing the
experimental designs um breeders are
very used to doing experimental designs
uh they're familiar with
the way that increasing replication will
increase
the procession of those means estimates
but then
we have done most of our trials have
been using balance the designs
across environments and that's very
inefficient
and so what we did is we tried and
showed a few strategies where we can do
is
optimize experimental designs first so
that we can have a higher productive
ability but also allocate our resources
in a more efficient way by not
replicating every single genotype in
every single location in the same way
but using our trials our network of
trial as our experiment
and then
distributing our genotypes across the
trial if we do that smartly with knowing
the mega environment so mega
environments are these groups of
environments that have similar ranking
of the genotypes so if we treat one
environment as one unit then we can
increase our productive ability and here
i'm showing how we can increase our
response to selection by about 40
percent by using those strategies using
the same number of plots of the same
resources as balancing everything and uh
and replicating everything but now by
using this unbalanced designs and uh not
replicating everywhere and treating the
mega environment as a unit and this is
called my environmental design
so
this changes uh the intensity um because
we are
being able to evaluate more individuals
it also changes uh the accuracy with
which we evaluate those individuals and
then the time
so um
other strategies to improve the um
the
response to selection is to improve
phenotyping and um and this has been
uh
booming in the last few years and there
are a lot of strategies at uh using high
throughput phenotyping and other
strategies to improve the response to
selection and again we need very good
models we need very good um
training data to build those models but
we can improve the phenotyping if we are
trying to protect um noise in our
training population then uh we're gonna
get noise right but if we improve the
way we phenotype then then we can
increase uh the response selection
because we're increasing the accuracy
um other strategies that we can use is
uh breathers we never work with a single
trade we usually have multiple trades
that are relevant
those traits tend to be correlated
and just
trying to focus independently on those
are usually not the best strategy but we
can use this correlation
to improve our productive ability and
sometimes that can help us protect
traits that are very expensive or very
hard uh to
to evaluate some of those are these
baking quality treats in bread
that are very expensive and when we do a
single trade and we try to predict it
the predictive ability uh
is not very large but when we use two
trades so a correlated trade to that one
we increase the productive ability and
this is using a full set uh so
um
uh using all the individuals uh in the
in the trading in the training
population phenotype for the for the
second trade but we can also allocate
those uh which ones do we phenotype for
the second trade and for the first one
in a smarter way if we purposefully
unbalance those
we can increase the productive ability
having the same
sample size as doing one trait at a time
so we can use those multiple traits in a
in a wise way
to improve the predictive ability and
then we can also use them in indexes and
other
ways or we can use them independently
and do independent culling or other
strategies that read our use
um this is another example of that
replace phenotyping and this was for
malting quality in barley where again
our goal was to predict some of those
molten quality that we do not have the
capacity lab capacity to phenotype all
the individuals in our breeding lines so
what happens is that we end up just
phenotyping for quality
the uh the lines that have passed our
agronomic evaluations and um and that
restricts a lot the diversity from which
we can select and also restricts their
progress but if we can phenotype earlier
uh because we use um code related traits
or we can predict them based on this uh
training population then uh we can
predict uh our early lines and we can do
a
uh a better selection and higher
response to selection
so those are some of the strategies that
we have used in our program
using genomic selection to improve the
efficiency with which we do the
breathing
i'm going to pass a an advertisement
here so there is going to be a session
in the agronomy meetings that are going
to happen in november uh where we're
going to discuss some of the designs for
predictive agriculture so i invite all
of you to attend and encourage you to
submit
and then with that i'd like to thank you
and thank the organizers for the
invitation and i'll be happy to take
questions